i was never dean's list
i was a b student
all the way
and one of the things you learned at
these late
schools and universities is you are not
the sharpest tool in the shed
and
that's anyway what i was realizing
and so in the poker game of life i had a
not very good hand what do you do well
you can pull off
or um
you can leave the game
and what i sort of did any of the not
only would the fraternities not have me
the eating clubs wouldn't happen i was
so asocial
and so if that's the situation what do
you do
and i think what i realized is
if i tried to compete i would always
lose
but when you invent
it's not competition yet
yeah and so inventing became my mode and
it's just a question of acquiring a lot
of skills to that you can apply to
starting things
and you go and discover other people
starting things to either help them do
that
or
learn from them how to do it
and and then the people who start things
tend to find each other the ones who do
it well
and that was that was my
that was my gang uh lots of different
people at different times
but uh
we hardly ever competed